hey guys it's Justine and today we are
checking out the Lenovo IdeaPad gaming
Chromebook now I would say most of the
time when you think about a Chromebook
your first thought might not be for
gaming but this changes all of that this
is the world's first laptop built for
cloud gaming thanks to Lenovo for
sponsoring a portion of this video now I
recently have been back to traveling and
having the ability to take gaming on the
go with a light and portable device is
really appealing this features a 120
hertz QHD display for high-end Graphics
there's no installs needed and you'll
instantly have access to thousands of
games it's also really nice because you
get automatic updates from the cloud so
you won't have to worry about your
device ever being out of date this
keyboard is a multi-zone RGB gaming
keyboard which is very nice for typing
when or if you decide to take a gaming
break and do some work this laptop was
built to play and I can definitely
relate with that because I have been
playing video games for pretty much as
long as I can remember I think I started
playing when I was maybe like four or
five and I remember my mom getting me
like my first console and it was pretty
much the most exciting thing ever I am
curious though to hear from you guys
what do you think you were built to do I
would love to hear it so leave them in
the comments below some of your favorite
hobbies now one of mine is something
that I started a few years ago
saver training some of you might know
this some of you may not it sounds a
little bit strange but it is so much fun
now unfortunately I did have to take a
little break from training due to a
blood clot and a crazy Health scare that
I had earlier this year and the
repetitive motion of doing sword
training and lightsaber training caused
this whole thing I I don't really want
to get into it there is a video if you
want to check out more information about
what happened but I haven't been able to
do my fun hobby as much or as often as I
like but I wanted to show you some of my
lightsabers that I have been collecting
so let me go get them and then we'll get
into gaming okay so I've got some Sabers
here
now when I first started this it
actually stemmed from a martial arts
called Kali which is a Filipino martial
arts which is usually done with like two
weapons I started doing that and then my
trainer Orion who's absolutely
incredible we decided like a couple
years ago that we were gonna try to do
like a Christmas lightsaber video so we
started training the lightsabers never
ended up making the Christmas video but
I got super into basically like staff
spinning sword spinning and it was just
like the most fun ever when I first
started I was so bad I think I have some
footage of like when I first started
doing this it was so embarrassing like I
couldn't even look I couldn't move my
feet like the foot placement like
everything was just an absolute disaster
because not only do you have to be able
to spin you gotta move your feet at the
same time so there's so much that goes
into it which when you kind of do it it
just looks kind of seamless but then
when you actually try to do it it's very
difficult so I wanted to show you some
of my Sabers I want to show you where I
started this was like the first saver
that I ever got this is I mean it's so
destroyed it actually is broken in fact
and we kept training with this for
probably like a year not this specific
one I think I had like I probably have
gone through like 10 of these they were
not very durable but they're super light
so they allow you to kind of do oops
sorry top camera they're super light so
it kind of allows you to really move
quick but for doing actual combat not so
good I probably am going to start
actually spinning with these again just
because it is a little bit lighter and I
feel like that'll put a little bit less
pressure on my shoulder and I may even
kind of switch to doing it left-handed
which is kind of interesting I'm
actually a left-hander but most sports I
do right-handed which doesn't really
make any sense I don't know it just is
what it is so these are the other Savers
that I have these are the ones that I
started training with when I met a guy
named Nate in Hawaii who was also like
an incredible lightsaber martial artist
so he showed me these lightsabers and
actually it's kind of crazy because last
year we came out with the iJustine
series lightsaber so this is one of the
IJ Series this is in the gold this comes
in a black which I have loaned to Orion
my trainer and then I have a silver one
which is at home in Pennsylvania so I
have the two gold which I actually will
do dual spinning with these
um I'm not that great at it but I can
still kind of do it now this is one of
my favorite ones I think this one might
actually be charged are you charged
you're not charged that's sad it's funny
because these are lightsabers but I
really rarely ever turn them on because
most of the times when I'm training it's
during the day there we go it's so great
oh it has a motion sensor in it it also
has a clash sensor so
if you hit something it does actually
make a sound like you've hit something
okay low battery please charge
and yes but this one is also very fun I
have spun this in the past and it is
it's really heavy it's also kind of
difficult too because you have to watch
out for the extra little Savers here on
the side this one I basically just have
hanging up in my weapon rack and the
last one that I have here is this silver
one this one is also dead
um there is a charger with them and they
are super easy to charge but like I said
most of the time when I train and since
I haven't been training often these have
been just sitting looking beautiful on
my weapon rack so these are just my
combat Sabers these are ones that I
actually made when I went to Disney they
are custom they are super heavy and they
are not for battling so I do have a wide
variety but these are my favorite
because the fact that they are combat
and I know a lightsaber is supposed to
light up I just like them for battling
we're officially back from the
lightsaber Hall and it's time to test
out some games the first thing that I
loved so much about cloud gaming is you
don't have to download or install games
but I also was able to sided with this
Nvidia 3080 accounts and I have a free
month subscription so I was kind of
testing this out but I'm able to log
into some other gaming providers where I
have games already purchased and I can
play them in the cloud we're living in
the future the future is here
so now it's time to game and I'm so
excited to try this out I have only done
a bunch of cloud gaming basically on my
phone I've never done cloud gaming on a
Chromebook before I do truly believe
that cloud gaming is the future not
necessarily even just gaming but editing
and being able to use high processor
intensive resources on cloud devices on
something that isn't as powerful as the
device that's actually running in the
cloud so this is really cool and I do
believe that this is the future
especially with 5G connections and
internet getting faster it is only up
from here so I'm going to be playing
Jurassic world Evolution 2 and I
actually already have this in my steam
Library so we're going to hit play this
is also a new game that I did just
download to try out which I'm so excited
I'm a huge fan of Jurassic Park so I
love the fact that I'm able to play this
it's something that I already have
inside of my library I do own the game
but I'm basically playing it in the
cloud using my steam account so we are
ready to go
steam has launched on my cloud device
and Now's the Time here we go
home already let's just start the
campaign and check it out just let's
remember that this is running on a
Chromebook the game that I'm playing now
and this looks fantastic
this looks so good wow our memory
with one goal and this looks really fun
I've never played one of the Jurassic
Park games before
let's drop one of these in
place this in the area shown okay
okay we'll keep okay locate priority
dinosaurs in the surrounding area even
approaches that you use R to switch to
aim mode and then I fire oh my gosh this
is gonna be so fun
let me transport you here
there he goes there he is there he is
delivered to his new home
oh my gosh look at him having the best
time
certainly recognize this dinosaur okay
so that was a nice little test of
playing Jurassic world Evolution 2. now
let's see if we can play something a
little more simple this is more of a
party game and I actually used to play
this game all the time whenever I would
have friends over and it's probably on
one of my top favorite games of all time
overcooked and this is overcooked too
all right we're just gonna play a new
story game I haven't played this in so
long all right let's grab a lettuce
okay great okay we've chopped the
lettuce we're gonna put another plate oh
I'm so nervous
okay great we've got that I think I'm
I'm barely gonna be getting anything
accomplished
get your get pick them up I just gotta
get my controls down great great we did
it we did the best that we could do
can we all got another
don't think we can do it no pick it up
no one of us no we're not gonna get
it again time's up okay I think we did
pretty good for our first time playing
this normally I play with the controller
so learning these keyboard controls is
all new to me so far I'm really
impressed with this the fact that I'm
able to play processor intensive games
basically on a Chromebook is pretty
impressive so if you guys have any
questions I would love to hear them in
the comments below and be sure to check
out lenovo.com for more information
about this Lenovo Chromebook I'll see
you guys in my next video don't forget
to like comment and subscribe and hit
the Bell to be notified when I post new
videos I'll see you guys in the next one
bye-bye
foreign